mais cyril images du jour c'est bien sûr
ces milliers de parisiens qui étaient
sur l'esplanade des invalides et qui ont
été délogés par les forces de l'ordre
tout avait bien commencé il faisait beau
les parisiens étaient en train de faire
un kiff sur la pelouse bronzage pique
nique partie de uno bien entendu
exactement délai chifoumi etc
sauf qu'au bout d'un moment il y avait
un peu trop dont certains sont même
étonnés étant donné la situation
sanitaire et ça ne s'est pas trop bien
finies les forces de l'ordre sont venues
pour disperser tout le monde
regardez c'est notre image du jour vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez vous
chez vous et vous ici autour de la table
bien entendu tu sais que vous êtes très
occupé toute la journée mais vous
travaillez quand même l'émission je sais
que vous n'avez pas l'avis de bill
clinton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il était très sympathique et drôle
débordements nom et tout s'est plutôt
bon enfant
les gens se sont dispersés de façon
vraiment voilà convivial n'y a pas eu de
gros alors si vous trouvez normal que
les forces de l'ordre soient intervenues
pour disperser la foule vallée de cette
façon là en plus oui ils sont pas
arrivés en étant des cowboys en disant
sortez de là tous etc
non ça s'est fait de façon plutôt
souriante et oui effectivement il
s'était posé pour le bien de tous donc
être chaud et en essayant de disperser
les uns et les autres tout en leur
disant pouvait rester mais par petits
groupes de dix en respectant des
distanciation entre chaque groupe et
cetera bien sûr puisque depuis les gens
sont pas bêtes sur soi en ce moment il
n'ya pas le sait pas le ton se rebeller
en fait donc il n'y a rien à dire quand
le collet la police vient battu par es
tu mates rebeller donc c'est vrai que
même eux ils donnent ne pas leur en
vouloir quand ça se passe et tout cela
dans la bonne humeur
oui c'était bon enfant de parts et
d'autres arrivent avec cette phrase 10
et 10 120 ce que ça c'était plutôt drôle
et les jeunes s'attendait vraiment à les
voir débarquer quand il prend soin aux
messieurs dames et ben voilà c'est le
jeu c'est chacun chaque partie de ses
ébats isabelle vous a fait une phrase
savez quand vous êtes chez vous vous
inviter des potes à la maison et il ya
toujours votre d'art ou qu'il y ait dit
m
alors les jeunes qu'est ce qu'ils font
ça sort ou maintenant alors c'est
l'aquarium
c'est quoi ça se passe où un oeil
bavasser ça c'est vous d'ailleurs votre
fils va bien c'est une bonne mine et
j'aimerais bien monter une nouvelle
ailleurs excusez moi bien entendu on est
dans perdu vous m'avez reconnu jacques
prix là c'est comme ça la pradelle mai
mais la version tunisienne
jacques prévert
oui moi je comprends pas ce que c'est le
fruit d'une au geste ou pas aux gros
sécurité bah oui parce que mine de rien
la plupart des parisiens ont envie dans
des petits studios dans des petits
espaces de vannes et à l'extérieur
il fait 30 à paris les parcs sont fermés
les terrasses sont pas d'horaires et
donc une seule raison à des squats et le
moindre quart que ban mètres carrés de
pelouse à deux c'est vrai dans au moins
six ils ouvraient les terrasses rien que
ça et on donnait la responsabilité au
bar restaurateurs de mettre en place la
liste à sion social franchement ça
désengorgerait le les avaler du crew
vrai patron serait pas quatre émissions
l'année prochaine sur et ça c'est sûr et
ça ça c'est acté ça c'est sûr ça oui
jean-michel mais fille était sur les
invalides avec thé et des copains et
copines de la fac serra non respectant
évidemment les mesures de sécurité et
ils ont pas été délogés élan et polis
les policiers surveiller ce manque les
gens respecter les gens qui respectent
et il est il avait le droit devrais je
sais pourquoi nous envoyer votre fille
pourquoi pour envoyer un comme un envoyé
spécial pour bosser sur les missions ce
qui faisait que plus je veux dire par
mois 2 r si michel ravaux bras voit une
fois de plus voilà vous êtes vous bossez
plus que jamais charité voilà bah je
sais ça fait ce n'est si nou lé pas bien
si nous n'arrivent pas dans l'elite one
mais je le sais la rue ce poste au
mirail allait s'efforcer et je sais je
sais oui deuxième chose deuxième chose
maxine là où max de raison c'est qu'on
fait avec deux minutes à s'approcher
grâce à la personne alors elle lui avons
dans l'émission tpm b il était toujours
dépressif et maintenant c'est devenu
faudel
[Rires]
et on adore c'est la tournelle avec
massa je sais comment je gagne je suis
content j'ai fait je suis content du
matin je rentre à minuit j'étais fatigué
des fois là j'ai rien foutu depuis
cinquante-cinq jours pouvait pas ça
quand je suis content de voir des armes
gars peut pas le prendre là même pas le
danger
merci alors monsieur qu'est ce qui lie
alors monsieur claude malheureux comme
on l'appelle et moi ça me va non mais
alors faudel oui c'est vrai qu'ils ont
ils ont par exemple à respecter lesdits
les dix personnes sont faut respecter un
peu ouais il faut des gens la chance
d'avoir les invalides heures par kamba
deux pas de chez eux
turpin normal de laisser les parcs
fermés quand le métro est ouvert non moi
ouvrez les parcs avec des peut-être des
gens qui patrouillent ou un an ou deux
policiers bien faire respecter mais
arrêté parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
parlé à la chance d'avoir espace des
invalides j'aime pas de moi hier un pote
s'appelle pierre qui tu travailles pas
du tout dans le noir et chaussée qui me
disait il faudrait il m'a dit ouvrez
ouvrez la cage mais s'est laissé
s'envoler c'est beau la mer
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment donné
faut être cohérent si tu si tu mets les
gens dans le métro laisse les gens ont
regardé par jamais volts secondes sur
les parcs la fermeture des parcs et
après ils sont 13% et par exemple son
tour l'ouverture des parcs
le gouvernement va être obligé de céder
parce que là elle est mieux les knicks
en train de céder table ou encore que
vous avons envoyé quelqu'un sur le
terrain bravo d'envoyer mon fils de 6
ans c'est bien vous intéresser à ces
chroniqueurs le cfai sont pas bien sûr
l'année prochaine je m'intéresserais à
la personne qui va vous remplacez la
police évacue les cela valide appareils
wi à 89% donc normal à 89 est pas normal
à 11% vous êtes une majorité à être
content maxime gay ni même sur n'a pas
tout à fait compris ce qu'il a dit mais
c'était sympa d'avoir votre intervention
merci il faut dire quand même que 82 %
disent c'est normal mais 82% il sait pas
que des parisiens les gens de province
ils savent pas ce qu on vit aussi à
paris m'a arrêté avait alors fermé
j'aimerais bien habiter à la campagne
arrivez vous barrez vous quand ça
t'arrange en guise de punition je
redonnerai la campagne gens veulent tous
mais arrêtez de dire des bêtises d'oeil
à la campagne à 30km y aller mollo y
aller on dit pas de bd on ne vous a pas
demandé d'inviter batteux retrouvé il ya
des aléas liés baisses passées en
voiture il va faire un bon c'est vrai
c'est n'importe quoi là jean michel
enfin fils de paysans colombiens de
généreux toi il pleut à l'accompagnement
le fait chaud ça va vous faire du bien
merci